[Applauso]
buona sera per tutta la mia vita
professionale ho cercato di convincere
persone ed aziende ad essere e
comportarsi in maniera sostenibile
qui vedete una damon ha un'immagine che
è uno dei modi più efficaci che ho
trovato per spiegare l'importanza della
sostenibilità
vedete l'andamento della popolazione nel
tempo vedete che dall'inizio dei tempi
per decine di migliaia di anni il numero
di persone sulla terra è stato pressoché
costante o perlomeno cresceva molto
lentamente
poi a un certo punto è cambiato qualcosa
e la gente ha cominciato a riprodursi
selvaggiamente a ritmi forsennati e
quindi vedete schizzare questa curva
rossa verso l'alto questa è la prova
scientifica primo che mia moglie mi ha
detto per anni delle bugie non è vero
che le donne tutte le donne hanno mal di
testa dopo le nove di sera e la seconda
cosa interessante da vedere è che questa
velocità che ha del vertiginoso a
dell'infinito mal si concilia con quello
che è la dimensione finita del pianeta
dallo spazio voi potete vedere la terra
con una palla che non cresce al crescere
degli abitanti rimane evidentemente di
dimensioni infinite e di dimensioni
infinite sono anche per definizione le
risorse e che lì sono contenute o
perlomeno la velocità di rigenerazione
di queste risorse è finita vedere
insieme queste due immagini fa capire
quindi che bisogna trovare un punto di
equilibrio ci sarà un momento in cui
quelle persone quando cominciano essere
sempre di più dovranno definire il
proprio stile di vita e in maniera
adeguata alle capacità del pianeta di
sopportarci altrimenti ci saranno dei
problemi
un'ultima velocità che io vedo guardando
questi grafici a queste due immagini
vicino è la velocità di adattamento
della delle persone del loro stile di
vita alle capacità e alle capacità del
pianeta
sì la velocità non è
commisurata alla crescita per esempio
esponenziale che vediamo del numero di
persone ci saranno pasticci sempre più
importanti l'ultima cosa forse la più
importante che vedo in questa slide è
che le donne avevano ragione a me
personalmente costa molto ammetterlo
però quando si parla di sesso e di
riproduzione purtroppo è evidente che le
dimensioni contano
questo è definitivo almeno le dimensioni
del pianeta
uno dei problemi che dicevamo prima se
l'uomo non è capace di adattare il
proprio stile di vita velocemente alle
capacità del pianeta ci saranno dei
pasticci uno di questi è il cambiamento
climatico che oggi vediamo
sono fiero di dire che laiche tra 17
anni fa ho lanciato il primo progetto al
mondo ad occuparsi di cambiamenti
climatici e il progetto impatto zero
cosa abbiamo fatto
siamo andati a lavorare con migliaia di
aziende per calcolare le emissioni di
gas effetto serra dei loro prodotti
ridurre per quanto possibile e poi
abbiamo compensato queste missioni con
la creazione di nuove foreste capace di
ripagare il debito con la natura cioè di
riassorbire queste missioni per
mantenere quindi questo equilibrio che
dicevamo col pianeta
siamo riusciti a toccare più di 400
milioni di prodotti che sono andati sul
mercato e non ve li sto visto che vi
vogliamo bene
non ve li sto a elencare tutti però
vedete che abbiamo toccato proprio tutti
i settori dall'editoria dai libri alle
padelle dal cibo ai grandi eventi
guardando dietro a questi prodotti
vedendo cosa succede dietro alle
fabbriche che ci portano questi prodotti
in casa abbiamo capito quello che quasi
tutti gli scienziati ripetono da tanto
tempo abbiamo mille problemi ambientali
ma la priorità
il problema più grave è il nostro
utilizzo dei combustibili fossili
in particolare perché bruciandoli questi
sono la causa maggiore del cambiamento
climatico che oggi purtroppo vediamo
parlando di velocità purtroppo siamo
stati totalmente inadeguati
nell'affrontare questo problema ci
abbiamo messo più di 30 anni per
arrivare a parlare della soluzione a
trovare
una soluzione come l'accordo di parigi e
subito dopo già un secondo dopo nella
realtà stiamo facendo delle cose molto
strane e che contraddicono
questa firma per esempio l'accordo di
parigi dice molto chiaramente che non
possiamo neanche pensare di emettere di
bruciare più di un quarto delle riserve
fossili che oggi sono presenti sul
pianeta già disponibile conosciute ma
ciò nonostante noi stiamo continuando a
trivellare anche in zone del pianeta
particolarmente dedicata delicate come
l'artico questa dal punto di vista
scientifico è una follia e ci fa capire
quanto ritardo abbiamo nell'applicare
quello la conoscenza che abbiamo la
conoscenza scientifica che abbiamo in
questo momento
in questi anni una decina di migliaia di
profughi hanno messo in crisi l'intera
europa a causa dei cambiamenti climatici
e dei combustibili fossili
gli scienziati ci dicono che nel questo
secolo quindi entro questo secolo
entro il 2100 avremo tra i 50 e 200
milioni di profughi ambientali ma anche
questo spauracchio non ci fa applicare
le soluzioni con la velocità adeguata
questo è è la vera domanda questo è il
vero paradosso perché le soluzioni oggi
esistono
noi possiamo produrre energia da fonti
rinnovabili quindi pulite come sole
vento e l'acqua e non dai combustibili
fossili in maniera affidabile
tecnologicamente affidabile ed
economicamente profittevole e
conveniente però stiamo applicando
queste nuove sostituire queste nuove
soluzioni per sostituire le centrali a
combustibili fossili con una velocità
che è meno di dieci volte di quella che
avremmo bisogno di applicare in questo
momento e le risposte a questa domanda
del perché non applichiamo queste
soluzioni velocemente possono essere
tante e io appunto mele sono opposte me
la sono posta questa domanda per per
tanto tempo una delle soluzioni più
interessanti che forse non abbiamo
proprio il
cervello programmato non abbiamo il
cervello adatto per affrontare problemi
lontani nel tempo e nello spazio ma
siamo sempre solo concentrati sul
problema contingente nel tempo e nello
spazio deve essere vicino a noi abbiamo
provato in tutti i modi live che da far
accelerare questa velocità di 3 nella
transizione energetica dei fossili alle
rinnovabili partecipando e dando voce
alla scienza e dall'altra parte anche
alla religione alle religioni questo è
uno da una foto di uno degli eventi che
organizzato in expo ci sono più di tutte
le maggiori religioni del mondo dicono
quello che dice la nostra quello che
dice l'enciclica di papa francesco che
il creato comunque lo volete chiamare
delle risorse del pianeta che abbiamo
sono molto preziose ma neanche questo
invito così chiaro di tutte le regioni
evidentemente se avrà qualche cosa ci
abbiamo provato in tutti i modi come
dicevo anche usando i modi più pop
usando testimonial e canali un pochino
più pop che forse funzionano meglio per
muovere le masse delle cose troppo alte
però anche qui i risultati del come la
gente veramente pronta a muoversi e
cambiare le proprie abitudini sono
sempre abbastanza deludente se voi
chiedete alle persone in italia se sono
interessate alla sostenibilità avete
delle risposte confortanti più del 59
per cento abbiamo presentato ieri i
risultati dell'osservatorio nazionale
che facciamo con il professor mannheimer
sugli stili di vita sostenibili e quindi
se l'anno scorso era il 59 per cento la
percentuale di persone che in italia vi
dicono che sono interessate o
addirittura appassionate di
sostenibilità
da ieri breaking news su 2018 questa
ricerca ci ha portato fino al 64 per
cento
al 74 per cento cioè cresciuto di ancora
15 punti
però questa maggioranza silenziosa non
si vede
se guardate alle decisioni che in realtà
la società sta prendendo in questi anni
è per questo che abbiamo provato
focalizzarci a cercare di capire anche
che cosa blocca anche guardare in quella
parte un po scura non solo tra gli
appassionati interessati ma anche
tagliati guardando in tutte le domande
che il professor mannheimer ha posto a
questo campione rappresentativo della
popolazione italiana questa è una
ricerca seria fatta su più di mille
persone con tutti i crismi scientifici
di una ricerca di mercato di un sodaggio
professor mannheimer è uno dei più
famosi sondaggisti che abbiamo in italia
bere una domanda era la seguente i tuoi
soldi li può investire in due
investimenti che da un punto di vista
economico sono esattamente identici pari
rischio e pari il rendimento
l'unica differenza in queste due opzioni
in questi due investimenti diversi è che
uno dei due farà in modo che i tuoi
soldi siano investiti in attività che
rispettino l'uomo e l'ambiente
l'altro no bene che cosa avranno
risposto i nostri eroi
queste sono le risposte che abbiamo
avuto
vi invito a focalizzarsi sul 14 per
cento di persone che ha detto per non
saper né leggere né scrivere
io preferisco che i miei soldi se devono
andare a finanziare dell'attività vadano
a finanziare delle attività che
disturbino rechino danno all'ambiente e
all'uomo possibilmente anche alla donna
questo è questa è una risposta per me è
incredibile perché il 14 per cento e
tanto è perché per me questa è la prova
scientifica che abbiamo scoperto una
nuova specie
oltre all homo sapiens evidentemente ora
abbiamo di fianco anche l'uomo
deficienze e ho deciso di chiamarlo così
per due ragioni la prima da un punto di
vista etimologico questi sono deficienze
dal latino perché gli manca un pezzo gli
manca un pezzo di comprensione non hanno
capito che inquinare il pianeta qui vuol
dire un minuto dopo avere il cibo che
abbiamo nel piatto inquinato o l'aria
che respiriamo inquinata o l'acqua che
beviamo in cui
quindi la prima ragione è una questione
etimologica la seconda è che ai miei
occhi parlano paiono proprio deficienti
non so se rientra nelle parole ostili
però mi sembra il minor il minor la
miglior cosa che si può dire quando
abbiamo cominciato a focalizzare questo
che è un problema proprio cognitivo
questi non riescono a capire c'è
qualcuno che proprio la pensa in maniera
molto diversa
ben ali miss spalancate le porte e ho
portato una seconda scoperta che passerà
negli annali della storia dopo la
relatività di einstein e soprattutto
dopo la legge di moore e soprattutto
dopo le leggi di murphy passerà agli
annali come la legge di molteni bene il
numero massimo legge di molteni dice il
numero massimo di persone che possono
stare sul pianeta e funzione del loro
quoziente di intelligenza evidente è
evidente se tutti fossero deficienze
come quelli di prima è evidente che ci
possono stare meno persone di una razza
più evoluta di una specie più evoluta
quando parliamo di intelligenza il
quoziente d'intelligenza in questo caso
deve misurare l'intelligenza
propriamente detta e anche
l'intelligenza emotiva cioè l'empatia
che abbiamo quelle cose che ci stanno
intorno quelle cose e quelle persone per
renderla più facile se la volete mettere
su un grafico adesso non ci sono le
proporzioni giuste ma per aiutarvi anche
da un punto di vista visivo alla legge
di molteni dice questo
più siamo intelligenti quindi più gli
spostati in orizzontale col quoziente di
intelligenza che va a crescere più
persone possono stare sul pianeta
possono riuscire a vivere sul pianeta
quindi all'estremo destro la stima è che
se avessimo solo persone così se
avessero una persona una popolazione
costituita solo da dei super sapiens
potremmo starci forse anche in 500
miliardi o forse anche di più potevamo
starci in tantissimi man mano invece che
andati indietro sull'asse orizzontale
evidentemente questo numero potenziale
scende fino ad arrivare forse anche a 0
dipende dal mix che abbiamo nella
popolazione dalla percentuale di
deficienze ed i sapiens le due specie
saranno in lotta
le due specie saranno in lotta per
davvero perché fanno avranno difficoltà
a comunicare perché le basi sono molto
diverse e quindi sarà interessante
andare a vedere chi vincerà
per farvi vedere un'applicazione pratica
della legge di molteni vi comincia a
dare qualche riferimento oggi più o meno
uno più uno meno siamo 7 miliardi e
mezzo sul pianeta
se volessimo andare a vedere con un
quoziente di intelligenza che lo stile
di vita che abbiamo in italia la legge
di molteni ci dice che dovremmo essere
circa 2 miliardi
questo cosa vuol dire vuol dire che
abbiamo solo due opzioni o ne ammazziamo
cinque miliardi e mezzo
a partire da quelli che sono fuori da
questa sala oppure a troviamo una
seconda opzione
miglioriamo il quoziente d'intelligenza
medio della popolazione per spostarci
sull'asse orizzontale fino a incontrare
la curva cioè fino ad andare ad avere
uno stile di vita e un intelligenza che
ci permette di starci in 7 miliardi e
mezzo in maniera sostenibile sul pianeta
queste ricerche le potete trovare da
mille altri scienziati del mondo che ci
sono arrivati da altri calcoli sono
quelli che vi dicono per esempio che se
tutti volessimo vivere con lo stile di
vita che abbiamo in italia oggi
servirebbero quattro pianeti
peccato che nella realtà è uno solo ne
abbiamo bene ora arriva la parte pratica
dobbiamo riuscire a capire chi di voi è
sapiens e chi di voi ed efficiente per
questioni di privacy abbiamo deciso di
fare un test in realtà che andrà in auto
valutazione
qui trovate il risparmio ambientale il
vantaggio ambientale che si porta che vi
porterete a casa
facendo una di queste azioni green
andare in bici tutti i giorni al lavoro
invece che usare la macchina mangiare
solo cibi biologici diventare
vegetariano tre volte al giorno tutti i
giorni che dio mette in terra guidare
un'auto ecologica cioè scegliere l'auto
più eco tra quelle sul mercato ognuna di
queste azioni meritevoli a un risultato
ambientale e quindi su quali sono i kg
di co2 che risparmiate ogni anno se fate
quell'azione e vedete che l'ultima
colonnina è un po più alta delle altre
qual è la colonnina del risparmio
ambientale che avreste scegliendo
energia prodotta da fonti rinnovabili
per casa propria
ora il test evidentemente non era per
capire qual è l'azione più importante
perché qui ci arrivano anche i
deficienti
è evidente che scegliere energia pulita
per la propria casa e da tre a quattro
volte più importante di tutte le altre
azioni che non vuol dire che non bisogna
fare anche le altre ma vuol dire che
questo è il risultato dei scegliere
energia rinnovabile per casa propria se
vi sembra molto strano pensate che il
vostro frigorifero e anche altri
elettrodomestici funzionano ogni secondo
di ogni giorno che dio mette in terra
che voi siate lì a guardarli oppure no
quindi abbiamo elettrodomestici che
continuano a usare l'elettricità che
oggi ha prodotto da combustibili fossili
che generano tutto quell'impatto che
appunto potete andare a evitare abbiamo
deciso il test del sapiens che il vero
punto il vero parametro che distingue
sapiens da deficienza è la velocità con
cui una volta che ha capito qualcosa
applica le soluzioni agisce il parametro
che vi volevo dare sono cinque giovani
laura hicks è scattata adesso perché
informazione l'avete se entro cinque
giorni
riuscirete a mettere almeno una di
queste azioni a terra potrete fregiarvi
della appartenenza alla specie dei
sapiens per chiudere
il sapiens generalmente sono molto
indaffarati perché hanno un sacco di
cose da fare ed è per questo che noi
abbiamo lavorato nell'ultimo anno per
sviluppare un progetto digitale che
permettesse di scegliere energia
rinnovabile a casa propria senza disagi
anche per le persone che non possono
realizzare lavori per esempio non
possono mettersi i pannelli solari sulla
casa perché non hanno magari la casa di
proprietà o non hanno i soldi per farlo
abbiamo sviluppato un progetto digitale
che vi permette di scegliere a casa
vostra di ricevere a casa vostra solo ed
esclusivamente energia elettrica
prodotta da fonti rinnovabili italiane
certificate senza costi senza lavori in
casa senza problemi senza costi
aggiuntivi evidentemente altre città
dovete pagare lo stesso se deciderete di
farlo entro cinque giorni è questo il
mio appello vi troverete in buona
compagnia come vedete è l'appello che
faccio è di fare perché sono le azioni
che facciamo e non le parole che
definiscono chi siamo è il nostro futuro
grazie
[Applauso]